former democratic presidential nominee
seth moulton just took a trip he was one
of those two people unauthorized to go
into afghanistan yesterday with
republican representative meyer
seth moulton
that high profile name in democrats
is saying there's no way we're going to
get everybody out we just simply will
leave americans behind i mean there's
not just a little bit of headwind
against the president of the united
states it's a wall
oh there's a lot look adding to that
list you're right to mention seth
moulton also adam schiff adam schiff's
uh saying that it's unlikely adam smith
also a democrat saying it's very very
unlikely
kevin mccarthy no possible way brad
sherman a democrat saying you're not
going to get everybody out and this is
just the handful of people acknowledging
reality unfortunately our president will
not it is so shameful that on friday he
looked into the camera and made this
commitment quote we will get you home to
americans he went even further and said
to our afghan allies quote we're making
the same commitment that was friday here
we are this week and that commitment has
gone by the wayside there's no
transparency here
meantime as you watch the pentagon
briefing they have a detailed percentage
list of the members of our military who
are vaccinated point by point branch by
branch but they still cannot talk about
that the number of americans caught in
afghanistan it is just stunning
communications catastrophe all the way
across from the pentagon to the state
department right on down to the white
house
so morgan i want to drill down on that
just a bit because when people leave the
country they have to flash their their
passports everything's digitalized now
how in the world can we not know which
americans are over there in afghanistan
i mean it's not like it's a tourist
destination and a pandemic and people
trying to sneak to get there
yes we've got a couple different issues
going on harris number one you would
think in the months leading up to this
withdrawal since the president announced
it in april that we would have started
pulling those lists together and getting
that information together one of the
things that the state department relies
on around the world is something called
safe uh this system where people are
supposed to uh register with the u.s
embassy so that they know they're there
they know they're present so you've got
one problem in that this should have
been done ahead of time and then the
next problem we'll see what secretary
blinken says in the next uh hour
whenever he's supposed to go to the
podium if they've been able to get that
number to us but an important point
harris uh this is not the first time
that we have had to evacuate americans
out of a crisis last year during covent
when the world shut down and commercial
airliners shut down mike pompeo in his
state department
we had to evacuate and repatriate almost
100 000 americans from around the world
this was a huge logistical feat so it's
important to note that the state
department can't do this there is the
capabilities but they have to have the
right political leadership in place
secretary pompeo empowered our under
secretary who's essentially like the ceo
of the state department to get this done
and he put direct people directly
reporting to him who would be
accountable for getting a hundred
thousand americans home to me the
question is why has secretary blinken
still not done that where is the point
of failure at the state department who's
responsible is anyone in this entire
administration going to be held
accountable for this debacle i don't
think they're going to fire anybody they
just hope in the next few weeks
if secretary blinken starts to take
questions that things stay tougher on
him than they did in that previous
pentagon briefing that we got out of by
like the sixth question on the same
thing and we had been given all of those
details i mean jen griffin was trying
for fox news others in the room were
trying but but they just simply their
goal today it seemed with kirby and and
the major general just don't make any
headlines
just just you know just keep this line
tight right now it's a very military
thing to do by the way uh having grown
up military i've seen hold the line i
want to get to this sorry before i come
to you we had two republican congressmen
on last hour one was the first green
beret elected to congress mike walsh
from the state of florida and also the
chairman that the ranking member of the
house foreign affairs uh mike mccall of
texas here they are now
now with the president deciding that
august 31st
is the the the the date where the
military's gonna be completely out
i always say there's gonna be blood on
his hands people are gonna die as a
result of this decision we are on the
cusp paris of having the biggest mass
hostage situation in american history
it's going to make 1979 and tehran look
like a sleepover because you're gonna
have thousands of americans left behind
that the taliban will then have for
leverage when they want international
recognition they want money they want
economic assistance and they've got a
gun to the head of american citizens
because joe biden left them
uh and i just want to say this ari too
about
congressman
walsh he did some time as an elite beret
uh special forces officer in afghanistan
so he knows the lay of the land he knows
the taliban your reaction to some of
what you just heard
all right we're we're having some uh
technical issues with with ra
fleischer's microphone did i just hear
him again
can you hear me now okay go ahead ari i
just wanted to get your reaction i
apologize uh for having to come to you
again to get to repeat yourself but your
words are too important to skip
so we heard from the congressman in your
reaction
what i was saying is i've heard
criticism of presidents often in my life
but what's so different now is when you
listen to the tone of their voice
whether it's a democrat or a republican
but especially a veteran
it is so ardent because you're so scared
of things that can go wrong because this
is so perilous
and what you're criticizing joe biden
for is one his judgment and two the
accuracy of his words and here's biden's
core problem harris last week he became
before the american people and said that
americans were not having difficulty
getting to the airport when of course
they were he said there's no al-qaeda in
afghanistan when of course there is he
said he wasn't being criticized by
foreign leaders when he was
and now this week he says we're on track
to get everybody out after having said
that all americans will be brought out
and all the afghans who afghans who want
to be brought out too
can we rely on joe biden when he doesn't
know what's going on this is why people
have this edge to them this is why this
is so perilous because it appears that
the president of the united states is
not in connection with events on the
ground and is just speaking and wearing
rosy colored glasses at a time when we
need realism
that's why i think you hear this fear
and obviously all you have to do is turn
on the tv and you realize
how perilous it is for the people trying
to get to the airport
well and it is fear too because some of
what they've told us ari isn't and and
this started with the president then it
spread to you know the pentagon then jon
in the white house press briefing room
and it's these words
for every american who wants to come
home we will get you home
if you can't get to that airport how are
you going to read a woman or a man's
heart you don't know what they want
you can't even get them to the airport i
mean it's so disingenuous it's like it's
talking to us as though we're stupid and
at least we're in a safe space
right we're in a studio somewhere
they're hearing these same disingenuous
words it feels it must feel like hate to
them a world away go ahead ari
well and we're focused on kabul where
everything you said is valid but what
about maza sharif what about kandahar
what about the other cities where there
could be americans it's not as if
everybody's just in the one place where
there happens to be an airport but that
feeds into something else where jenn
saki yesterday was bragging that this is
going to be the largest evacuation in
our history
well that's because it's been the
largest abandonment of people in our
history the only reason we have to
evacuate people is because we abandoned
them and we went down this path that joe
biden selected to withdraw the military
first the proper way to do it is for
people who have caught commercial
flights over the last several months and
there'd be nobody left to evacuate it
should be the smallest evacuation in
history if it was done well it's only
going to be a significant evacuation
because it was done so poorly
did you see that video just then emily
of the people standing outside the gates
in the ho of the airport did you see
that that's why it's so hard to watch
that's pure sewage that people were
standing in it's the shot just before
this one
they're standing in sewage they're doing
whatever it takes to get in and i had a
former army ranger interpreter on with
me just a few minutes before outnumbered
started
he's worried so much about his family
he got out but he's got to get them out
now can you imagine standing in that
trying to get out you're getting sick
just trying to save your life because
lord knows what's in that water
this is tragedy upon tragedy harris and
i think the worst part for me as an
ordinary american is the notion that
this was in some way preventable the
notion that if there was some modicum of
actual leadership from our
commander-in-chief actual transparency
if there was an ability to listen to the
multitudes of plans submitted to him all
across the government by veterans by the
state department by the department of
defense and more that there would be a
more seamless transition a better
extraction than the absolute surrender
and abandonment we have seen up until
now and i'd like to hear more from
morgan on this because morgan i think
you touched on such a valuable point
which is that in the refusal to delegate
any type of responsibility or power that
is why everything is sort of bunching at
the top we're hearing from all aspects
throughout the government and again with
ordinary americans saying we have a
chartered flight we have everything
available available but we're missing a
permit to land for example we're hearing
from congressman gallagher saying why do
we keep surrendering our power to the
executive branch we have more power than
standing at a microphone let's pass
legislation and get these americans and
allies and animals home so morgan what
is your insight if any into that what
we're seeing that bunching at the top
resulting in i think inevitably loss of
life
well just quickly i think whenever you
have a lot of people in charge you have
no one in charge so one of the things
that congress will need to get to the
bottom of is where is the point of
failure at the state department
why weren't these civ applications being
processed
what happened between april and august i
think that's going to be the crucial
question at the state department under
mike pompeo he made sure that people
were appointed to positions and they
were in charge and they were held
accountable by him if they weren't
delivering trust me i've been in the
room when he's had to hold people
accountable
yeah i just have one question
is someone lying to us about what's
happening on the ground and who's making
the decision to do so because if the
president can honestly say and mean that
he doesn't know
about the dangers on the ground outside
that airport
and how deadly it's going to be
when our american military pulls out if
they're not telling him
that's one thing but if they're not
telling him so that we aren't told
that's tacitly a lie
and we can't accept that
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now